Mona mittend drin auf SRF wir
präsentiert V
folg eig Gag ich darf nicht mit fremde
fr auf n vorbereitet aber auf alles
gefasst
50 Mal Mona mitten drin
[Applaus]
überrascht
ich
[Musik]
über
ich
[Musik]
überwtig schwi und Mens mich und
mit das
schlim
[Musik]
Trunk für die 50 S ke blackbx ich
wes
Mike mit dem schwi und melie
schwer das ist mon drin die
[Musik]
50 der erste Ort W ich fürs Jubiläum
noch Besuche ist für mich der
schlimmste Restaurant der best
schwi
t mich vor jah trotz
unterirdis
herlossenh drin
50 verschiedene
ganged ich limitiert ja ich glaub mit
dir ist besser besr genau und was bra
für das Jubiläum es bra K wir machen ja
ich ma mich Berat dann los wunderbar
Tanja grandade Jubiläum 30 ST der jah
davor Restaurant in
Basel W ich miting ich drin kennt Mel
W
undf soruckt wie Sie einfach das
Schicksal und ihren Weg wie wieregangen
ist und der bringe ich dann am Schluss
dann der wie schönell was du für eine
die überleid natürlich mit Äpfel extra
für Dich nach unserem Apfelmus unser
apfelmusdkussion letztes Mal aber ich
glaub seither mach selber Apfelmus oder
manchmal
[Musik]
ja er
okay okay
ein vor
Hand ichf bestanden dass es
mus und St
wier kannst du mit dem apfelmusfangen
jawoh einf
sch so wie du da mach
ich
Vorschlag
viel
aberelau
jetzt wenn ich zwei P parallel
geistig
wir Formel
aber
so ist vor z Jahr wo
miruch Herz ganz viel mir noch selber
macht
pfelm wie schön wie schön also mit war
fangen wir an wir fangen an mit dem
Butter das muss kalte Butter sein ja
Mandel mit kokosflocke und brauner
Zucker einfach
verknete so genau ja wenn ich so auf die
50 send z ist enorm also magch dich
überhaupt erinneren wo du überall warst
a vom Asylzentrum üb Krematorium mit
koreanische Reisende auf der schinige
Platte
Kim was heißt
das
brfwimmer auf der
Kinderstation in St g ist so viel und es
geht immer wieder so die einzelne sendig
wieder so in S wie z.B die
der im Schutzwald und zwar drum will der
das ist ein für ganze Team V der
krassikop die Baum das ganze komplett
unzugängl also
das Kamera
ist
ja
ja vorne okay B
Z
knpp mon m drin ist nicht nur für m
Challenge sondern auch immer für ganze
Team
dahinter ums meh wenn Mens imflich Job
der Schwiz begleitet pro J verlz sich
ratistik
undil
alles
[Musik]
krass extrem Adrenalin unterwegs bin ich
mit zwei Forstwart Mike und Mario im
Wald g man nämlich nie allein ist schon
rechts Team schaffen oder ja ja ja zwei
schaffen Sch on ja das
so und der ist
WN genau der Macht ke oder macht nicht
ja
undhang
mit minander Situationen
erumständen es ist für
alle Nachinein ist das eigentlich nur so
was das wo den
Forst passiert ist noch viel viel
krass ihrem Gebiet ist der Waldbrand die
große waldbr von W und das ist so der
Moment ichagy ich muss wssen wie das ist
die sind
wir Wald
[Musik]
brennt juli vom letzte Jahr brennt W mit
all Mittel Versuch für Griff
über
tagelangatz
[Musik]
drin noch für bin ich mit dem Mike
unterwegs im
Waldbrandgebiet wie ist das jetzt für
dich
W
dasemlich investiert und inner kurzer
Zeit ist das alles dahin wo der
brandbrochen ist wie he das mit FR
durchfahen
unterhalb und brenn
fig war nicht so ganz geht ja bis jetzt
noch nich gehen zB und nicht h witer
geschafft das ist nicht g ja
Chef
Peter ma
SPR wie ich mir
vestanden ja
das
ma Helikopter sch geflogen B wenige und
die
flammeiesoß und das
ganzamme dieind 100
mE nicht vorstellen selber nicht
Video breitet sich Rasen schnell los
Helikopter flüg Z ständig aber
Sonnenbrand l sich mit Wasser nicht
löschen die einzige hoffn dass der Wind
und
richtigt
Mike Chef der revierfer peterier ist
Mitglied vom
krisenab Stuck geschaff zum für in Griff
jetzt sind wir unterwegs oberhalb V
Beach und wo ist
brandoch
das in der
Region losang losang irgendwo da und das
ist natürlich in einem
Tempo die Felswand das sehr R ja über
felsenegangen
jaw im Hal Z V Ries vierb wenn das G
meine Güte woestellt das vier keine
Ahnung also du Angst D das sich noch
viel witer ausbreitet es ist richtig
schangstig
alle und aber Star Wind oder ist das
eigentlich jedem logisch das Brennen bis
weiß nicht wo und da
dieag das nicht schaffen oder ja will
alle l vi jeder einfach möglich ma
ja ja sicher ganz klar also das ist
eigentlich bis Letzt ist
das
Funktion
oder morgen
Platz frem
undich
die oder das
war zum Glück Wind
schw und Kollege lö über 100 GL damit
der Brand nicht
wiederbricht alle gesund
wieder zerstufengrad ist verwürstig am
[Musik]
gröte jetzt VI
minutch
paü WN BR
so du le
mir ich B da for war geflich der Schwiz
aber noch nicht GewSt dass es denben
walbren geht überle du dir Meng W ich
das oder wird das irgendwn gefählich ja
g bist eigentlich gar nicht studierach
eigentlich interessant ja vi V dir h mit
der motorsage brennende die Bim
fend ja aber solange das nichts passiert
ist das sicher interessant aber ja aber
du bist jetzt Vater worden
V ja genau also die Frau macht die sich
ke Sorge wenn sie weiß m Z ein gefählich
Job ich weiß es nicht also sie noch nie
gefrag ja immer g aber was will D mich
GBE sie KNT michfang so dass ich das
schaff mit vertr vonand also wichtiger
EUR Wald ist das ein Schutzwald ist ist
das noch W einach nur no so störze h
Schutzfunktion also da so gut lawi oder
stechlag ne also vor allem jetzt die
rosionimmt wenn so Niederschlag geh das
oberflach Wasser geht
schneller der wird sicher der stelock
vor a Stieger und im Winter die beim was
noch steh oder die sch lawi ist
verhinder darum besser wenn man die L
wie lang g jetzt bis mir da ob wieder
ein leig Wald so
mannshoch also du meinst mon hoch ich
mein mannshoch ja aber 50 Jahre ist son
son
grobe am Süd also hier Südhang
50 Jahre bis die be hoch sind ja ja also
die Tochter die wird sicher schneller
groß als die bäum sehr
wahrscheinlich
[Musik]
Geduld
genau genau die sind auch für der K
meine
lieblingsäpfel und welche von den 50
Sendungen ist jetzt so am meist bieben
also sicher die erste send das ist im
Gefängnis hey das kann man sich gar
nicht vorstellen Moment wo
duckä wo d Filze Handy abge und weiß ich
bin jetzt einfach da
drin unglaublich krass
Moment auf die
genau
Gefängnis
meist
stst im Kanton St h offen Vollzug ins
alles man sich Tag frei auf bewegen über
Nacht
sindpert
Dave da lang schn
mit ja ja
einum bin ich da was Einl sicher einmal
aber
aha
[Applaus]
kenst du schon im Gefängnis nein niem
also du W nicht zumindest ja genau genau
das wo vi verzähl od die lestell wo du h
in der Biografie wenn du schon mal im
Gefängnis aber du sind meist bieben und
körperlich wirklicho mich am meist
winterckelh will müssen marschieren und
mit der ganzen Pack od mit und der ganze
Pack also volle Gewicht auch mit der bup
das ist der Punkt oder also du TR als 50
kg Frau TR du gleich schwer wie der 150
kg Schwinger
ausal und das ist wirklich alsoich
Berechtigung die wird sehr konsequent
gbt und wirklich also
m aber ich gefunden schla machen einfach
zu Company
2 mal ABC a mötis zal kursbn dal
bet num
z
a
zwei er ich Schw schwer wie
[Musik]
nicht
okay
danke was hst
du das
war
ggen
sie wie sch wir na ich hab Gefühl es wä
wahrscheinlich wenn der Niederschlag
W
[Musik]
wär dar
ich minut Schlafs sie aber ich glau
nicht ich kann mir fast nicht vorstellen
dass es jetzt schlimmer werden
s g Nacht g
Nacht ganz viele viel fre zu mich da
der inklusive me
Vater so da h mal
gut ja was ich interessant vion de jung
gegangen zum spürre wie es ist zum
arschlag selber oder zum sich selber so
afder was ist so die hert die Z so hchen
die anstrengendste Zeit war die erste
Restaurant das man hattet das war im
turgau und ja natürlich ohne Mitarbeiter
wir war der Dreierteam und h am Anfang
alles alles selber gemacht und sie Tag
aufer gehabt und ja noch geschlaf
irgendwn nicht wirklich nein also noch
dem Service wirklich nur alles
abgewäsche Hotelzimmer putzt w e alles
gemt also das war ich denke so die
anstrengendste Zeit überhaupt körperlich
anstrengend ist das ein die Reportage wo
mich am meist berührt im sin wo mich am
schwierigste ist zum hushalt das ist auf
der
Neonatologie de früher geboren und das
kann man sich ein nicht vorstellen vor
noch nie gesehen die winzige Körper und
dann hast du all die Technik und du hast
so vielü und
lauich neonathologie im
Kantonspital ich bin Stefanie auf der
Intensivstation
das
zwiingsw sie sind 24 W
plus bis vom
jüngste wo man eigentlich so
Neonatologie
intensivpfleg und Medizin
betreut der DM ist vi m früh auf wel mit
nur gerade 500
g sind
zwielingsbrüderild
[Musik]
Finger jedes früher geboren da h K
tinterfisch zum sich draf Tentakel
erinnert Nabelschnur im Buch von der
m am ler deran Ramadani Ken der Papa von
der
Zwilling das sind die
Mens du und
ich
B jetzt schon zwei Wochen Tag und seh
was alles ist und was gemacht W und so
als Vater oder Elter Kön machen zum ihn
helfen wir könen und sich
Kraft
Kraft was ander Medizin undbe
Gott
[Musik]
ein Z
D infektionsgefah wie der früher
geborene ist groß drum Babys immer
wieder frisch sterilisiert die BR Züg
werde
[Musik]
daselterfang
nach
drei Nachricht über ein von der zwieling
der ist noch darzündig verstorben ein
unglaublicher Schicksalschlag für
Familie
[Musik]
Ramadani jah spter sie
wieder
mit beide schwion und auf
Spielplatz Familie Ramadani wohnt in
tüfalau keernt sich undan im Kosovo er
schwiwach
Frau wie
got
jetzt dan gut nach dem ganz wasstand
gut sind
seh mega mega me
mit ich alles erinner sehr sehr gut gest
ja ja Tag wieder V
mir und mich seh gut erinner aber wie
wenn ich jetzt soeh tut mir das ganz ver
schönere weil
jaund glücklich spielfreudig und dann ja
ja
stolz ST auf wasemacht
ja die
erste im
spitaleder
ich bin glücklich aber Angst habe ich
immer noch ja ich musste 24 Stunden
schauen ich musste schauen ob atmet
immer noch mit dem Angst ich könnte es
nicht ruhiger schlafen in der Tag
schauen
wow das Bucht so viel Kraft oder ja sehr
jetzt wenn ich überlege ich sage ich
frage mich selber ob ich wie gemacht
habe streng für die ganze Familie immer
wieder
Spital halbe jah ist jetzt aber stabil
gesund und
mter ich find bewundernwert wie und das
alles geschafft ihre Jünger Tochter ist
erst
sind so da
[Musik]
du große
woh ja
Hallogen fre m du bist Brüder BR und ihr
wohn alle woh
alle also wer
wohnt okay gen also ich der
Frau Brüder mit Frau vi
und ja okay wow würde so
le Mutter mit der Schw Schwerin W das
für damals unmöglich oder
dasüberwältigen ganz im Spital noch die
ja wirklich ganz ne
bin morgen
fah Nacht ja na
warum immer so wie got sind zwe sind
nicht zwe ja V allem wo der wirklich
nicht zwe worden ist ja dr mor gepackt
und ir
Gefühl du h
gespürt
genau Chefarzt Dr Meer gesehen dr
dannlich oder
mm ja genau ich habe auch geträumt und
ich habe gespürt dass etwas passiert
wirklich ja ja es geht nicht ein Tag
dass er in mein Kopf ist
ja also wenn mich fragt dann sage ich
auch ich bin Vater von zwei Töchter und
zwei burbe ja ja das ist so ja ja eine
haben wir da und eine
hoffe auf S Brüder
schutzangel ÜL sind tintefischus bruhkte
erinnert ih er bliebt im Herz von der
Familie heute bist du
wach die auf der Neonatologie wird für
immer ein prägende Teil vem le er zum
[Musik]
Pap
das das ist die erste windele
von so klein ja unglaublich erste sche
ja
ja neatologieit wenn du da schaffst dann
merkst du das Leben nicht
selbverständlich
ist auch nicht also ja der Mensch ist
halt leider so solange
gverstlich aber sobald
Gesundheit ist wichtig ja wenn zur
denkst die und wenn jetzt so D ja wenn
ich alles überlege ich sage dass der DM
ein Kämpfer ist und wir auch das so
stark
sind ja weil er hat viel überlebt
ja mega
scht hoff war sch selberes babyh auf der
Neonatologie ja D Hof veren das schon so
[Musik]
ja du aber sag mal das ist ja schon sehr
heftig was du alles verlebst weißt du
das wirklich nie wo es an geht ist das
immer Überraschung ich weiß es wirklich
nicht dass die FR meist gestellt wird
ich glaub es ist mega wichtig dass nicht
weiß ich so schlech
Schauspiel so als wä ich total
überrascht ja was noch viel fr du h
immer die richtige
Sache Team wirk wie standleit
zu
WoW hinter Ruck irgendwie bergchuh
verpacken oder irgendwie TR oder so also
wir all
hinterang
[Musik]
wow h du gern überrasch nein ich mag
Überraschung gar nicht also wirklich
überhaupt nicht also okay da bin ich
mega froh auch
[Musik]
überraschsp will nicht nein will nicht
will nicht nein drum eiglich die
send und gich muss ich s ist super ich
setz mich Sachen ich
freiwiig
ja und das
ist Blick verändert wenn Du kennenlernst
oder
Gass and wo mich irgendwie in quasi so
der drogesüchtige von Vertrauen B so
plöz mit ander Blick kann ich auf
die du kochen mit
mir
der andy ist einuch der Gasse und
langjährige
drogenekonsument hilft und Verdi sich
Geld
ja konsumierst du
[Musik]
denn warum blöde
Fr
probiert probiert
sch einfach so probiert oder
sch Hero
so
probiert
jeden Tag bis son geht der Gass Mittag
nicht gratis ESET
franint
alles F
ja
ewigit hoffe
ich du glaubst immer irgw ich danke
positiv
im so ist gut
gerade oben der Gass sind konsumationsr
für die
[Musik]
süchtigge alles
gut jetzt im Moment schwierig ST Exem
oder
also and W jetzterst Kokain Rauchen
s ihr könt schnell ich B schnell
da die aggressiv stimmig beruhigt sich
wieder Vater
hat
ja und
Ingenieur
[Musik]
wie Droge Menschen im Griff und was zT a
ih und ihrem Leben macht das ist für
mich her Z mitterlebe aber
Realität
wenn ich jetzt 5 jah
wieder warum wo bist
den
wir abschließend die Wort sind
[Musik]
nochst ja der and die hat rech jetzt F
jah später treff ich ih wirklich nicht
me der Gasse ich hab vor pa
über liebe Mona leider müssen wir dir
mitteilen dass Andy nach einem
Hirnschlag verstorben ist an seiner
Abdankungsfeier heute in der gasseuchi
haben wir euer Mona mitten drin geschaut
in seinem Zimmer hatte er bis am Schluss
ein Bild hängen von euren
Dreharbeiten also hat mich mega berührt
zum erfahreen dass M die das so viel
bedeutet h und mir selber mir so genau
gichegangen also die D T mit dem
Andy das ich wirk begegn wo mir blieben
ist drum Gang ich noch Gass zum meh
fahren über die letzte Z ich abgemacht
mit wo
g g hte Andy die letzte ze jah begleitet
als Sozialarbeiter vom drop in Luzern
oder and
met das ist der W ich
schluss
auf biologische Alter 20 bis 30 jah
einfach aufgund vom Lebensstil vom
Konsum ja und sicher auch V dem Stress
sie mit
ganz und das ist die
a bereits du Dazs
kennelernt betroffen vonusgeprägte
lungenank und nichtsdestotrotz ist immer
wenn es wieder ein G Tag
für hat hat so positiv Humor verloren h
du Erin
irgendwie ja der and mir nach dem
Dreh zwei F von dir und
ihm ist das
F oder genau das ist Doppel
vonim
das das das nach sowieso Fernseh Fernseh
und einfach andere wie große Wand das
und ja ich glaube mitum so
und de
Zimmer ja
lau viel
reaktionenö bekannt so in Luzern er hat
stimm über er hat das Gesicht über also
h mal wieder Gefühl hey ich B Mensch
zweit Klasse son wir sind Aug das H Wert
g ja h du gefü wo de da
F ich ja das glaube ich definitiv oder
es ist auchfah die K da jeden Tag auch
also
wir sie sind am Rand von der
Gesellschaft oder werd als das
betrachtet wirst du sagen g Schluss für
Familie ja ja
defini Platz und der
Ort und
gachtet Gass für vieleucher Heim derort
wo
sie Kontakt
zu oder
[Musik]
Familie ich
bekanesicht
J wie
hei und wie
lang
und h
m was mit der
Sucht immer
ein
immer bin ichull
also
m den gar
nicht wieder fr od
verantw
und
100%ar
nicht
vi Kontakt zu der Familie Verl wieso du
da geschafft zum
kontaktchhalten ich
ma
aber
und
jetzt h du denn VF
gemacht ich
z
ja
aber jetzt kom
gut WST du dir wünschen für Zukunft für
dich
ich mit sicher Scheiße gemacht aber ich
Bich
m
Gesundheit nur
einigerß Herz sch auch recht das ist das
ist das
Wichtigste das ist doch
W
ja
ja der ED hat das Ziel er will wieder
ein innere wärmig spürre auch ohne Droge
der Tel fredolin hilft dabi beid wüns n
best auf ihrem
[Musik]
Weg seeht super aus der der nehme ich
jetzt mit genau bring ich zu der Mel
rfall
und Zentrum und
sie ich mit
dem also alles
[Musik]
gutchü
ich bin gespannt wie der Melanie h
Gott bis zu ihrem Unfall für Melanie nur
ein richtig für mit sie schon ihren
eigenen rerhof geführt aber ih Passion
ist auch Schicksal worden W ich sie vor
5 Jahr paraplegik Zentrum troffen h sie
ihr le ne
m ich ke also ich weiß du bist da he
irgendwie genau
halswirbelverletz nach okay da genau Hal
oh le was neu üben musste ja wie man
sich streht ohne dass man den Rumpf und
die Beine selber ansteieren
kann das dir relativ
entspannt B das wie lange hab wir das
G ja bist
du ja ja da wo du frischist nach dem
rumfall was bist du ganz anders als da
wo ich jetzt daesehen ja ich bin ich
Kopf Z cm rechts und links K bewegen und
der rechte Arm ganz l und ich nicht K
bewegenar nicht g der linke nicht g und
das ist erst im Verlauf von der wier ich
glau sag ist relativ vieles anders gesen
du bist da gen und H noch ir mit der
Auge so machen und das alles gesehen
ja ich trifft Melanie auf rerhof es ist
nicht ihren eigen der hat sie aufge
redstunde gibt sie aber immer
noch hey hi hi hey so schön D
gesehen freut mich mega hi Steffi freut
mich das freut mich
hey und das ist der
he und das da das ist der wo fürü ist n
für für ponis der Tanja
grandit min essen wie geht's dir gut
danke viel passiert in den letzte 5 Jahr
ja da glaube ich was sind jetzt für
jahrind fün gute J für dich oder fün F
anspruchsvolle J der Hof W ich vorher P
ich ABG Z mal
der viele Sachen wo sehr schön sind und
es gibt Sachen wo schwierig sind aber
ich glaube das verändert sich im Le egal
ob passiert oder nicht ja was sind die
schöne also sicher dass ich Steffi keelt
habe und mer soam die güße ja die
weniger schöne ich hab wahnsinnig viel
Schmerz und das einfach immer wirklich
und das ist ja sicher mit würde ich
sagen der schlimmste Teil vom ganze was
sind da für Schmerze das sind so
neuropathische Schmerz ja einfach so ab
da bis fpitze und das ist das W
michag meistrt ja ja
s s ander J anderal jah
ja und du bist aber aus Deutschland
genau ja ich komme aus der Nähe von
Basel so Basler Grenze und bin jetzt
aber zum 11.2 auch wirklich fest zu mi
gezogen meinen Job gekündigt Wohnung
aufgegeben und jetzt ja jetzt sind wir
zusammen
hier und wie H die eigentlich
kennengelernt ja online über was
tindernder genau ja genau eigentlich
habe ich geguckt und ich hatte
mein Radius nur ganz klein eingestellt
auf 10 km ja weil die Benzinpreise
damals zu teuer waren da waren wir über
2 € bei uns my war gerade auf dem Weg in
den Urlaub und sie muss so in der Nähe
Basel gewesen sein als sie mir angezeigt
worden ist und dann habe ich sie gesehen
habe gesagt und die will ich
kennenlernen echt ja die muss ich
unbedingt
kennenlernen was ist daso du gesehst sie
ist im Rollstuhl h du dir das überleit
will ich das kann ich das oder
gar nicht das war für mich überhaupt
kein Thema also es ist auch nicht so
dass wenn ich jetzt von meiner Freundin
erzähle dass das erste was ich sage ist
ja sie sitzt im Rollstuhl we es gibt so
viele andere Dinge über sie zu erzählen
die so besonders sind als dieses sie
sitzt im
Rollstuhl sie zump sie hat das
eigesiniges Pony z.B das genau ja vor
allem die Power die sie hat
das ist wirklich ganz arg beeindruckend
es gibt eigentlich nie irgendwas wo ich
das Gefühl hab oh das kriegen wir nicht
hin also oder auch wenn es mir nicht gut
geht ja dann dann ist eigentlich klar m
fängt das ab für mich das was ich selber
nicht tragen kann das trägt m für mich
mit und das ist das was ich mir einfach
Wünsche oder oder auch vorstelle in der
guten Beziehung dass man sich
gegenseitig trägt wenn der andere gerade
mal nicht kann ja ja
ja ist so der stark der ist so
stark ich freue mich jetzt auf den
Kuchen das auch alles was wir von dem
Text können weißt du das eigentlich
immer die gleiche
Sache das Haus find ich
gut ja finde ich
nett im Moment wohnen Melanie und
Stefanie n aufm
riterhofigführt erm zweizimmerwohig ist
aber definitiv eng für beide sie sind
auf die Suche noch me neue die im
Luzerner Seetal aber es schwierig bis
passend zu finden also dar ein so danke
viel mal
Tanja ein Kuchen auf das Leben ist das
dasag passt super fein und wir jetzt die
Rechte kann nicht schlüss od meh wieso
okay ja und die kann ich ganz öffnen
aber
dafür Kraft ja das ist ja die neue
Realität ist einfach so wenn ich immer
denke das kann ich nemen und das kann
ich nemen und dies kann
ich nicht DAV
ichavav ich habe nie das Gefühl dass
ihrem alten Leben nachtrauert ja dass
sie bitter wird oder so genau das auch
wirklich in Ordnung ist so wie es es h
dankbar sie mit dem was t und für das
was h das Glück se W der num ist es
schöns Schlusswort han ich gemint aber
was h jetzt du da noch Minix
Box für mich noch überrasch für dich
noch überrasch
5 fol Achtung entweder irgendw und du
war oder in Altersheim wo
viid
wirklich
also noch Gede B erfahre zu was für Mens
dass es mich als nch
verschl
Menschen sind Herz V mon m drin danke
viel mal all den W ich 50 sendig Begleit
und W
[Musik]
und zum
festhal
[Applaus]
du der hätte
[Musik]
[Applaus]
Entschuldigung Mona mendrin auf SRF wir
präsentiert v
vololg